-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden returned
to the White House today
after Queen Elizabeth's funeral.
Of course,
now he's calling it his flat.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
80% of Americans said
that they have not cried about
the death of Queen Elizabeth,
while the other 20%
said, "No spoilers!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden appeared
for an interview
on last night's episode
of "60 Minutes,"
or as it was known yesterday,
"600 Minutes."
[ Laughter ]
"I ever tell you about the time
I almost met Warren G. Harding?"
[ Laughter ]
According to new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating has hit
an 11-month high.
Wow! Inflation really is
out of control.
[ Laughter ]
Attorney General Merrick Garland
administered
the oath of allegiance
on Saturday
to 200 new U.S. citizens
during a naturalization ceremony
on Ellis Island and said,
"We must not allow the fractures
between us
to fracture our democracy,"
which must have been alarming
for the new citizens.
"Congratulations!
Enjoy it while it lasts."
[ Laughter ]
After Florida governor
Ron DeSantis sent two planes
of migrants to Martha's Vineyard
last week,
Texas governor Greg Abbott
bused dozens of migrants
to Vice President Kamala Harris'
residence in Washington, D.C.
Okay. What's going on
with these governors?
It's like we radicalized
the Impractical Jokers.
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, now go up to him
and give him a bus ticket."
[ Laughter ]
In his speech in Ohio
over the weekend,
former president Trump said
that he had a
"very luxurious
and enjoyable life"
before he entered politics.
Dude, you didn't enter politics.
You went straight to president
without even trying.
Don't make it sound like you
gave up your medical practice
to go door-to-door, campaigning
for city comptroller.
You had a nice house,
and then, for a while,
you had two nice houses.
[ Laughter ]
Two radio hosts in New Jersey
are facing criticism
after voicing support
for teachers
who have been accused of
having sex with students.
For what it's worth, the radio
hosts have issued an apology
and a genuinely remorseful
sound effect.
[ Sad trombone ]
[ Laughter ]
Kanye West announced last week
that he has terminated
his partnership with
the clothing company Gap.
Instead, he's going
with Ann Taylor Loft.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
producers have announced
that "Phantom of the Opera,"
which is the longest-running
Broadway show,
will close next year.
Said one man, "Oh, sure, right
when masks become optional."
[ Laughter ]
"I was gonna leave it on!"
That was the monologue,
everybody!